Katie it's Ross Tucker really an honor
and a pleasure to speak with you do you
realize how famous you are right now
back United States can you sense that
when you're still down there with all
these other Olympians down in Brazil
they threaten me I'm so um no you know
I'm I was pretty focused on what i was
doing this week in Rio and I'm happy it
all went according to plan and I I met
all my goals but really right now I'm
just enjoying my last couple days in
real and I think it all starts to sink
in once i get home so you're 19 I got to
know what what's like on your cell phone
after you won the last race you want I
think all the swimmers I can adjust to
this but it's pretty important to not
not check the fun during during the week
because everybody back home I writes a
lot and you start refining the messages
you can stay up up a little too late so
I tried to try to get the best thing
right after I swam each night because I
had a very busy week but all the
messages really were we're really nice
to happen I felt the support from back
home what do you do now Katie both in
the short term in the long term well
right now I'll take a couple weeks off
from some training and i'll be getting
ready to move into stanford for my
freshman year and that's going to be a
big transition but something i'm i'm
looking forward to and i'll get back in
into training with the college team
there and start setting some new goals
so you can still train the same way the
next four years at Stanford because you
know for the 2020 Olympics yeah it'll be
a different team and I'll be enjoying
the college from the environment as well
as setting some goals for my
international for me as well and I want
to continue to stay at this level and
could hopefully represent the US again
on the world stage both at at World
Championships these next couple years
and then at the Olympics again for you
yeah Katie I just spoke to Dan who's
down there and we were talking about
Usain Bolt Michael Phelps and he brought
your name up as the most impressive
thing that he has seen down
air at the Olympics and people are
calling I'm sure you've heard the deck
right area and all kinds of stuff is
going on what do you think when you hear
a guy like damn Patrick or anybody say
it's the most impressive thing at the
Olympics so far and did you expect to
win by that much it's a great honor to
get that recognition I mean I I just
focus on on what I'm doing in the pool
and I know that I knew that all the hard
work would pay off you know I think
swimming really come onto the scene
every four years but honestly it fits
every year it's every day of training
and hard work and you know I I just had
a lot of fun with this team this year
and it was a pretty special team and we
all encourage each other and fed off of
each other success and just proud to be
a member of the 2016 Olympic swim team
well Katie we were swimming with our
daughters this weekend and our three
year old is can swim across the pool
underneath the water so we're calling
her little ledecky right now okay so you
know how you got that picture of you
getting Phelps is autograph from however
many years ago well we'll find out where
your sign autographs and Bethesda will
come down and look out because you're
about 12 years a row away from hurricane
hell and Tucker coming for you and all
your records hey Katie how do you get
the metals home I just carry him on the
plane pretty much all right around your
neck or in a bag pull in aback yeah that
is all sad PSA Katie thanks so much for
coming on really appreciate the time
thank you I appreciate it the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience